Speaker 1: This is and maybe an even stranger
video that I have to play for you today.
There's this guy, Roger Stone. Roger Stone
was a former associate of Donald Trump's. He
was charged, he was convicted. He was pardoned by
Donald Trump. And, you know, this week we've been
going back and forth about when Mike Pillow says
these crazy things. Mike Lindell, CEO of Mypillow,
does he believe them or does he not? And we
looked at all sorts of different evidence
pointing one way and pointing the other way. I
genuinely have the same question with the clip
I'm about to play for you. Roger Stone appeared on
some show who even knows what it is? Let's let's
see if we can figure it out. He appeared on Alija
streams, which is some kind of a religious show,
and he said that he has discovered that there
is a satanic portal at the White House and he
presents pictures which he claims proves it. Now,
again, my question is, is he for real or is he
just kowtowing to whoever is interviewing him?
And in this case, it's a religious nutter show,
so he has to bring some religious nutter. Let's
take a look, see if we can figure it out there.
Speaker 2: You can see it. It's very, very
clear. It doesn't move day or night. It's
harder to see during the day, but you see
it at night. And I'm absolutely convinced
about the inherent there. It is again, about the
inherent evil of what's going on in the White
House, what's going on in the country. Right. And
I think it's imperative that people know about
this, that people of good faith, the Christians
know about this. And we begin a national
essentially a prayer assault to close the portal.
Speaker 1: So I guess what he's pointing to is the
portal. If you're only listening, there are images
where there's almost like a smudge of some kind
above the White House. And it could be anything
from I mean, quite literally, a cloud, a lens
flare. I don't know. It's very, very strange. But
I guess that's the portal that he wants closed. I
don't know. Let's let's continue to.
Speaker 2: Close the portal. We were
born for this moment, and I have to
pursue that. I've been preparing this
form for this moment my entire life without even
knowing it. I just was a political warrior. But
this is no longer a war in the political realm.
Speaker 1: I for some reason, I'm struggling to
believe that this is his genuine belief. I don't
know what you guys think, but it's just it's just
not feeling like he really believes this crap.
Speaker 2: That's right.
And and I do know how it comes
out because I know how the Bible
comes out, but I don't know exactly what the plan
is. But I do know that closing this portal is
crucial to victory. Right. And I want others to.
Speaker 1: It's funny how other people are
nodding like. This is the first they've
heard of this portal, but yet they're
sure that it's crucial to close it.
Speaker 2: But I want others to see
it. You can look it up online. You can go
to that live camera shop every night, folks
down, by the way. I predict you they'll now
take it down so people can't see it. Right.
But but this is not some practical joke. This
isn't some conspiracy theory. I'm absolutely
convinced that this is it is demonic. Yep, it
is. And a portal. It is access to this earth
by those who are evil. And only by closure will
be will we be successful in saving this nation.
Speaker 1: Now, one of the questions that to
me, any time I hear stuff like this, I just
there's questions that seem natural, right? So
like, for example, when I hear about Noah's Ark,
for example, and they say they were there's two
of every species, a male and a female, it's like,
okay, well, it might be plausible if you think of
like, well, giraffe and hippo and two chickens and
whatever else. But do you really understand what
you mean by two of every species? We're talking
about? Two of every kind of snake, two of every
kind of bird. Look at how many different birds
there are. Two of every kind of little worm
and two. It starts to be kind of like, well,
is that really feasible? Another question about
Noah's Ark. What did the carnivorous animals eat?
Because if you had two snakes and two mice,
snakes eat mice. So did the mice survive? Well,
no. We had two of each type of mouse. Plus extras
for the snakes to eat. Well, but you didn't say
that at first. The story is that there were just
two. These are the types of questions that my
mind go to go to. And so where I get to this
is a satanic portal for them to come to Earth.
Where are they coming from? Are we talking about
demons or are we talking about aliens? And if
it's aliens, where did they come from? And if
it's demons, where do they normally live and
why do they even need a portal? In other words, if
demons are really ethereal and omnipresent. Why do
you need a visible portal? Don't they just appear,
particularly if they are deputized by God? Would
it just never make sense? And if you ask these
questions, it's always, listen, the we it's it's
too complex for us to even understand God works in
mysterious ways really. Well, if that's the case,
then why would they use such a simple, visible
portal? It seems so obvious. If you can see it,
why wouldn't they come in a more discreet way?
You'll never get answers to this stuff. Good
luck. But you'll never, never get answers to this
stuff. My question again is, do you think Roger
Stone is sincere in this belief? I don't think so.
I think he knows this is nonsense. I think he is
just placating whatever audience he's in front of.
We have a fantastic program for you today. Sign up
at join Pacman dot com to get instant access to
the bonus show. But we have so much upcoming for
you here and then we have the bonus show. And then
tonight I'll be streaming the Trump rally live
from Nebraska. This one doesn't start until 9 p.m.
Eastern. I'll go live at 8 p.m. Eastern, so I hope
to see you then. But we have a hell of a show for
you today. The David Pakman Show is funded by our
audience. It's an incredible thing. It's not a
money tree. It's not some rich entrepreneur or
oligarch funding the show. It's just
people like you. You sign up at join Pacman
dot com, you get the show commercial free, you
get the bonus show produced every day exclusively,
exclusively for our members and everybody loves
it. You can sign up at Join Packman AECOM.